les républicains de laine
vice-présidente du Sénat rapporteur du
projet de loi pour le plein emploi dont
on va parler dans quelques instants mais
d'abord on l'a vu dans l'actualité la
Cour des comptes qui a donc remis son
rapport hier sur les recours au cabinet
de conseils et les sages confirment ce
qu'a dit le Sénat dans sa commission
d'enquête dérive sous la présidence
d'Emmanuel Macron ils estiment que
certains recours sont inappropriés
comment vous réagissez ah mais moi je
pense que on en a fait trop certainement
et puis en plus on a des fonctionnaires
de haut niveau qui peuvent faire le
travail et si moi j'ai regardé aussi sur
sur le covid en fait on a commencé avec
50000 euros pour les prestataires et il
s'est monté comme ça et le total des
prestations arrive presque à un milliard
d'euros donc c'est quand même
inadmissible pour en fait des sujets qui
sont des sujets français et qu'on doit
appréhender avec nos fonctionnaires et
puis il y a un sujet aussi sur la prise
de décision parce que là ça veut dire
aussi qu'il y a un gérance quand même
donc je pense que c'est un sujet grave
et important et qu'on doit absolument
effectivement encadré comme la préconisé
le Sénat avec comme la beauté le
proposition de loi elle est bloquée
l'assemblée ne s'en est toujours pas
saisie est-ce que vous demandez à ce que
l'assemblée sans saisie rapidement ah
bah bien sûr puis avec la Cour des
comptes je pense que ça va être appuyé
mais ça dérange ça c'est sûr que ça
dérange l'exécutif la maladie financière
bien sûr vous pensez que l'Assemblée
nationale s'en en parle pas bien
évidemment est-ce que les républicains
pourraient s'en emparer du coup dans une
de leur niche oui mais ce qui est assez
que comme c'est un petit groupe
maintenant les niches elles sont pas
nombreuses en fait c'est ça le sujet
est-ce qu'il faut aussi réfléchir au
recours par ces cabinets de conseils par
les collectivités parce que les
collectivités locales aussi elles ont
recours à ces cabinets de conseils
est-ce que là aussi il faut réfléchir à
ça
je pense qu'il faut qu'il faut regarder
s'il y a des abus voilà c'est toujours
ça en fait on peut prendre des conseils
en revanche là c'est l'abus c'est
surtout ça en fait qui a fait qu'on est
réagi et qu'on ait mis en place cette
commission d'enquête on va parler des
100 jours puisque les 100 jours arrivent
à leur thème les 100 jours Premier
ministre par Emmanuel Macron son jour
d'apaisement avait-il dit Emmanuel
Macron qui avait donné pour tâche à
Elisabeth borne notamment de relancer le
dialogue et de chercher une majorité
est-ce que la mission est accomplie pour
vous ah non je pense pas du tout déjà
100 jours moi je me dis c'est un début
de quinquennat de premier quinquennat
donc c'est assez surprenant non non je
ne pense pas en plus il y avait dedans
aussi les sujets le sujet immigration
qu'on repousse tout le temps parce que
justement la difficulté va être d'avoir
une majorité donc non non c'est
absolument pas alors il y a
effectivement une relance sur le
dialogue social ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment important les syndicats demain
vous pensez que ce dialogue soci
je ne dirais pas jusque là mais en tout
cas bon voilà il y a une porte qui est
ouverte et je pense qu'elle est
importante et sur la majorité parce que
Elisabeth borne elle défend sa stratégie
du texte par textes en disant que les
textes sont adoptés par le Parlement qui
a pas de blocage à la raison alors il y
a pas de blocage alors si on parle du
Sénat mais nous on vote notre texte donc
à chaque fois on avance sur le plein
emploi c'est c'est ça aussi après elle a
pas de majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
ça c'est vrai c'est très très compliqué
et même si les textes sont adoptés au
Sénat ça correspond pas forcément à ce
que souhaite le gouvernement et après
dans les commissions mix paritaires ça
peut être ça peut être un peu un peu
compliqué mais en tout cas nous sur
cette stratégie où est-ce qu'il faut
travailler un accord avec les
républicains sur certains grands textes
ah oui mais nous on fait pas d'accord
hein voilà non non mais non mais même là
sur le texte pleine emploi moi je veux
dire bien sûr moi j'ai vu à la fois le
ministre qui essaie de me dire non pas
ça pas ça pas ça
mais un accord et notre président Gérard
Larcher l'a dit ça se fait au début du
quinquennat ça se fait pas là ah oui
complètement oui oui donc là il y a plus
possibilité de travailler de prendre
quelques grands textes et se dire voilà
on se met d'accord là dessus on se met
d'accord là-dessus pour vous c'est pas
tenable non non non on travaillera quand
même parce que nous on n'est pas pour
pour bloquer le pays mais en revanche
bien entendu pas de pas de signature
comme ça en sur un chèque en blanc bien
notamment la loi immigration qui devrait
arriver alors Olivier du stop me disait
hier que ça serait pas pour le mois de
juillet mais plutôt pour la rentrée
est-ce que là-dessus vous pensez qu'un
compromis est possible Elisabeth Bank
dans Le Parisien elle est optimiste sur
un accord avec les républiques
heureusement qu'elle est optimiste voilà
mais je sais que quand même alors ce
sont pas mes sujets mais mes collègues
sont bien sûr avec avec des lignes bien
et des textes sur l'immigration des
propositions de loi on en a fait
énormément qui n'ont pas été prises donc
le gouvernement c'est très bien ce qu'on
attend en fait ce qui bloque touche à la
question de l'emploi que vous suivez
puisque c'est cette question de
régularisation des travailleurs
étrangers dans les métiers en tension ça
pour vous c'est une ligne rouge malgré
les difficultés et vous les connaissez
des employeurs à trouver et plutôt
favorable moi j'ai un chiffre 17 % en
fait de personnes l'immigration qui sont
au chômage donc est-ce qu'on doit en
faire entrer davantage après on peut
faire des choix sur des sur des métiers
ça déjà été fait d'ailleurs donc ça on
peut avancer mais c'est vrai que voilà
on a aussi beaucoup de personnes qui
sont encore au chômage
aujourd'hui dans notre pays est-ce qu'on
doit pas plutôt s'attaquer à ça et puis
essayer de les amener sur sur l'emploi
et c'est quand même le texte qu'on est
en train d'examiner qui dans une
meilleure organisation meilleure
partenariat devrait amener davantage de
personnes en emploi donc pas d'accord on
l'a compris il y a des rumeurs de
remaniement est-ce que Gérald Darmanin
qui est issu de Laurent issu DLR fera un
bon premier ministre ah bah je dis ok en
plus
je connais bien Gérald Darmanin
effectivement mais bon esquiver
je ne sais pas parce que c'est compliqué
le profil pour vous c'est pas le bon
profil mais je sais pas si un bon profil
en fait parce que le gouvernement le
Premier ministre aujourd'hui il y a
quand même une cassure avec le président
de la République et le gouvernement et
avec le président de la République on va
voir l'actualité dans votre département
on va retrouver Jean-Marc chevaucher qui
rédacteur en chef adjoint au Courrier
Picard bonjour Jean-Marc merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous Jean-Marc on va revenir
avec vous sur les émeutes qui ont secoué
la France il y a quelques jours après la
mort du jeune Noël tu es par un policier
après un possible improbable refus
d'obtempérer l'heure est au compte
à la suite des dégradations Jean-Marc
bonjour madame oui j'ai choisi de vous
parler ce matin des
émeutes dans l'Aisne vous savez surtout
à travers un effet de loupe sur une
petite ville que vous connaissez bien
Saint-Quentin 55000 habitants qui a
connu une nuit d'émeute
tout à fait
étonnante puisque ça fait partie des
petites villes où on s'attendait pas à
avoir arrivé ces problèmes et Gérald
Darmanin dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure
est venu le lundi essentiellement pour
soutenir les commerçants alors je pense
que ça leur a fait très plaisir mais
au-delà de ça comment faut-il faire
d'après vous et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on peut proposer pour que pour
pouvoir l'avenir on ne soit pas
confrontés à des situations similaires
alors en deux minutes et demi ça va être
compliqué en fait de vous répondre parce
que il y a plusieurs plusieurs sujets
bien sûr là c'est la jeunesse en fait
les enfants très jeunes qui se sont
attaqués au commerce en plein dans un
quartier où ils ont besoin de leur
commerce ça ou effectivement il y a un
peu délinquance mais jamais à ce point
là donc la responsabilité des parents et
certainement engagé mais il faut les
accompagner aussi les parents c'est pas
de dire voilà c'est de leur faute mais
je pense quand même qu'il faut revoir la
parentalité qui moi est un sujet que
j'avais regardé déjà il y a plusieurs
plusieurs années et je pense qu'on n'a
pas on n'a pas suffisamment regardé ce
qu'on pouvait faire pour accompagner les
personnes il faut accompagner où il faut
sanctionner parce que les LR on a
l'impression qu'ils sont plus sur la
ligne de la sanction pour les parents de
mineurs délinquants c'est sanctions et
notamment sur les allocations faut les
deux en fait il faut les deux il faut il
faut une sanction bien évidemment mais
il faut aussi faire de la prévention moi
j'ai toujours à coeur de faire plutôt de
la prévention et de ne pas arriver à
avoir ce sujet et surtout en fait il y
avait des parents aussi avec eux avec
des sacs pour pour piller enfin c'est
enfin pour moi une catastrophe et notre
mère elle a été vraiment très choquée
par les images de de violence et nos
commerçants et c'est vrai qu'à 50 ans
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on avait pu
envisager Jean-Marc
écoutez c'est une réponse alors après
quand on parle et voici on regarde quand
on parle des parents dans ces milieux et
dans ce quartier on parle souvent d'un
parent c'est souvent des familles
monoparentes c'est une chose alors par
ailleurs quand mes parents eux-mêmes un
site même parfois les enfants habillés
je crois que
éduquer les parents ça me paraît on
parle très très loin mais oui mais oui
parce que ça fait je pense plusieurs
générations en fait où on n'a pas eu de
réponse et voyez bien on respecte même
plus le l'instituteur je préfère
toujours garder ce nom on les respecte
même plus les élus bien sûr mais
l'instituteur donc au niveau de
l'éducation nationale il y a aussi une
forme de faillite dans le quartier
justement de Saint-Quentin quartier
Europe on a une école avec des deux
institutrices qui proposent des projets
qui s'appelle Socrate 02 et puis en
revanche on peut pas le faire on peut
pas le faire on peut pas faire des
expérimentations alors que ce qu'elles
font c'est vraiment formidable et elles
intègrent à la fois les enfants à la
fois les parents dans un projet qui est
effectivement qui correspond pas du tout
à ce que le directeur académique attend
mais est-ce qu'il faut pas justement
soutenir soutenir ça parce que
l'éducation nationale est essentielle
aussi
il y a une alors il y a la question des
parents mais il y a aussi la question
des biens puisque il y a eu beaucoup de
dégradations dans les communes
concernées il y a une loi d'urgence qui
va être présentée jeudi en conseil des
ministres pour accélérer la
reconstruction et pour aider les
communes vous la voterez cette loi
certainement certainement on va
peut-être la demander aussi donc comme
toujours
elle est nécessaire pour vous oui oui
Jean-Marc une dernière question vous
avez eu toutes vos réponses
non on n'a pas toutes les réponses mais
je crois que
de toute façon c'est un sujet évidemment
complet quand on va pas comme du Lamin
on va pas résoudre le problème en deux
minutes et demi ça serait mais
simplement
je pense qu'au-delà de la répression
comme on a vu tout à l'heure il faut
bien envisager autre chose notamment à
cause de tes familles qui sont
monoparentales et puis en raison de ces
parents disons souvent eux-mêmes des
délinquants enfin en tout cas qui on l'a
vu on la comprend encouragé les enfants
à pied donc
tout est tout est à refaire et sans
doute pas avec cette bière
et puis comment ne pas tourner la page
tout de suite et faire un travail
justement sur le long terme
Jean-Marc on regarde une du Courrier
Picard c'est le président du club de
foot d'Amiens à la une du Courrier
Picard il prend un gros morceau de Go
Sport c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup Jean-Marc chevaucher
d'avoir été avec nous Jean-Marc bel été
et puis on se retrouve évidemment très
vite merci Jean-Marc d'avoir été notre
invité on va parler de du projet de loi
pour le plein emploi puisque vous êtes
là rapporteur de ce texte parce qu'elle
Grigny et le Sénat avait commencé son
examen hier ça va durer dans les
prochains jours on regarde les temps
forts de la séance d'hier avec Alex Pusa
[Musique]
bonjour Alex bonjour Pascal grenier et
Alex avec ce texte le gouvernement veut
donc se rapprocher du plein emploi
effectivement on le rappelle
actuellement le taux de chômage en
France et de 7,1% et l'objectif du
gouvernement pour 2027 c'est d'atteindre
les 5% de chômage c'est-à-dire une
situation de plein emploi alors avec ce
texte et bien la première mesure pour y
arriver c'est une réorganisation du
service public de l'emploi et de
l'insertion l'opérateur actuel Pôle
Emploi deviendra France travail et agira
dans un grand réseau France travail
composé de différents acteurs que ce
soit l'État les collectivités les
missions locales pour l'insertion des
jeunes Cap Emploi pour les personnes en
situation de handicap et puis les
différents partenaires publics et privés
l'idée c'est de coordonner ces
différents acteurs pour offrir aux
demandeurs d'emploi un guichet unique
dans son parcours d'insertion
professionnelle alors il y a une mesure
dans ce projet de loi qui fait beaucoup
débat et qui a été discuté euh hier au
Sénat c'est la mise en place d'un
nouveau contrat d'engagement pour le
demandeur d'emploi pour le bénéficiaire
du RSA il devra réaliser 15 à 20h
d'activité par semaine formation travail
d'insertion et en cas de refus et bien
le versement du RSA ou de l'allocation
pour l'emploi sera suspendu
temporairement et il sera reversé de
manière rétroactive une fois que ce
contrat sera respecté un contrat dans la
logique qui a été vivement critiqué hier
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat par les
sénateurs de gauche
c'est 60% des allocataires du RSA ne
sont pas inscrits à Pôle emploi c'est
d'abord parce que 40% de ceux qui sont
dans cette halo de chômage ont des
problèmes de santé et c'est aussi parce
qu'on a locataire du RSA sur 4 est en
difficulté vis-à-vis du logement ces
problèmes sociaux réclament des
politiques sociales ambitieuses pour
lever des freins à l'emploi et non une
politique de sanction et de contrôle qui
ne feront comme l'ont démontré les
chercheurs l'ortie Le Gall et s'arrhéon
qu'augmenter le non recours voilà alors
dans le débat le ministre du Travail au
lieu du socle a estimé que ce contrat
d'engagement était en accompagnement
nécessaire vers l'emploi on va l'écouter
le but de toute façon c'est le retour à
l'emploi je suis parfois assez surpris
d'entendre que il ne devrait pas y avoir
de contreparties qui me ferait pas y
avoir d'engagement en matière de retour
à l'emploi lorsqu'on parle d'allocation
retour à l'emploi ce qui est le nom de
l'indemnité versé par l'inédith ou de
RSA avec le a d'activité qui parfois
disparaît des débats donc ce contrat il
est fait pour accompagner vers l'emploi
y compris en prévoyant des phases
d'insertion sociale quand c'est
nécessaire alors ces 15 à 20h
d'activités par semaine c'était une
promesse de campagne d'Emmanuel Macron
mais dans le texte précisément et bien
le gouvernement n'a pas inscrit à cette
durée de 15 à 20h minimum d'activités
car et bien le ministre du Travail
estime qu'il devrait y avoir des
dérogations pour certains à bénéficier
du RSA qui connaissent des difficultés
et qui ne peuvent pas réaliser ces
heures d'activité mais la majorité de
droite du Sénat à elle estimée qu'il
fallait inscrire cette durée de 15
heures minimum dans la loi et ça donc
été voté par les sénateurs notez aussi
que ce projet de loi pour le plein
emploi a pour but d'améliorer le service
public de la petite enfance pour que la
recherche de garde ne soit pas un frein
à la recherche d'un emploi on le
rappelle un gouvernement veut créer
200000 places de créer supplémentaires
d'ici à 2030 et la commune avec ce texte
devient pleinement autorité
organisatrice de l'accueil du jeune
enfant parce qu'elle Grun sur l'ensemble
de ce texte déjà est-ce que vous pensez
que ce projet de loi va permettre
véritablement d'atteindre le plein
emploi alors ça moi je peux pas vous
dire oui parce qu'en fait c'est sûr que
c'est une meilleure organisation
peut-être
c'est surtout la gouvernance partagée
qui est importante
après les partenariats existent déjà
mais en revanche c'est l'accompagnement
j'irai individualisé qui va demander
beaucoup de moyens financiers donc si on
n'a pas les moyens financiers on y
arrivera pas voilà donc on a les
promesses mais il y a rien dans le texte
sur ce plan là on nous parle de 2,3
milliards 2,7 mais en fait on sait pas
du tout c'est pas fléché donc c'est
vraiment le sujet si un meilleur
accompagnement je pense effectivement
qu'on arrivera à ramener des personnes
et à les aider à aller vers l'emploi et
à trouver un emploi alors l'une des
mesures qui est vraiment discutée et qui
fait débat dans ce projet de
RSA c'est pas c'est pas nouveau donc on
a enlevé réciproque mais à l'intérieur
c'est un contrat il y a deux parties
droites et devoirs pour tout le monde
c'est à dire à la fois pour l'opérateur
et à la fois pour le pour le demandeur
d'emploi mettre 15 heures oui c'est un
minimum mais c'est 15 heures d'activité
je rappelle c'est pas 15 heures de
travail et dans les 15 heures pour
certaines personnes ça va être déjà un
parcours santé parce qu'il y a des
personnes qui peuvent pas aller vers
l'emploi parce qu'ils sont mauvaise
santé que depuis longtemps en fait ils
ont négligé donc ça va être ça ça va
être aussi sortir de chez eux parce que
beaucoup de personnes aujourd'hui et
puis la crise sanitaire a pas arrangé ne
sorte pas donc il y a pas de lien social
créer un réseau enfin voilà l'activité
donc pour moi il y a pas de souci pour
trouver les 15 heures d'activité qui
devront être trouvées pas forcément par
le demandeur d'emploi mais aussi par la
personne qui va qui va accompagner mais
c'est 15 heures le gouvernement parlait
mais c'était pas inscrit dans la loi
vous vous avez souhaité que ce soit un
screen noir ressemblant pourquoi le
président de la République il nous en a
parlé donc on respecte on fait ce que le
président de la République dit mais dans
les expériences je vous disais il faut
que ce soit un objectif faut pas que ce
soit inscrit dans la loi vous avez pas
entendu cet argument il faut qu'on
inscrive un nom un nombre d'heures et
c'est aussi des déjà dans
l'expérimentation en fait là
actuellement il y a 18 départements qui
ont des territoires en expérimentation
le mien aussi et puis dans le contrat
d'engagement jeune aussi il y a aussi
ces 15 20h donc voilà on l'inscrit dans
la loi en respect de ce qui de ce qui a
été dit voilà je sais bien que ce sera
pas facile pour tout le monde parfois
vous pensez que ça sera maintenu parce
qu'il va falloir trouver un accord avec
les députés voilà ça pour vous ça sera
une ligne rouge ça c'est 15 heures
inscrite dans la loi
alors en cas de non-respect de ce
contrat il y a une suspension temporaire
de la prestation sociale qui est prévue
avec un versement rétroactif une fois
que le contrat est respecté et là encore
la droite sénatoriale a voulu être plus
ferme sur le et bien cette sanction en
cas de non respect du contrat
oui alors bon déjà les suspensions les
radiations ça existait aussi
auparavant mais là ils ont le
gouvernement ajouté suspension
remobilisation donc nous ce qu'on a fait
sur sur le la suspension pas de souci en
fait est de reverser pourquoi pas si ça
remobilise bien évidemment mais on l'a
effectivement borné à trois mois parce
que sinon quelqu'un qui arrive au bout
d'un an est-ce qu'on peut appeler ça une
remobilisation et il va demander il va
avoir droit en fait à un an de RSA donc
c'est pour ça qu'on l'aborder et le
gouvernement était d'accord aussi sur
sur ce sujet
autre
tous les accords avec ce texte vous me
souhaitez pas vous que Pôle Emploi
change de nom parce que Alex l'a dit ce
texte qui vise à créer un grand
organisme France travail pour que les
allocataires et les demandeurs d'emploi
n'est plus qu'une seule porte d'entrée
et dans ce qui est prévu c'est que Pôle
emploi ne soit plus Pôle emploi mais il
s'appelle également France travail vous
voulez pas pourquoi mais déjà parce que
le réseau complet s'appelle France
travail et l'opérateur s'appelle France
travail déjà il y a une certaine
confusion soulignée d'ailleurs par le
Conseil d'État aussi et puis après une
forme aussi de hiérarchie et ça ça nous
a été vraiment dit et vraiment beaucoup
par les missions locales notamment qui
ne changent pas de nom la mission locale
ne change pas de nom Cap emploi ne
change pas de nom et Pôle emploi va
changer de nom et s'appeler France
travail et en plus je sais pas si vous
allez regarder mais il y a eu le rapport
de Thibault Guigui rapport de
préfiguration dans lequel il y avait un
schéma et où au niveau des de la
gouvernance tout le monde était au même
niveau collectivités territoriales et
puis les partenaires sociaux et en
dessous vous aviez un schéma des
opérateurs avec Pôle Emploi Pôle emploi
devenu France travail et en dessous
Mission Locale donc ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle chez nous des irritants voilà
donc je pense que au contraire ça
fonctionnera bien s'il y a des bons
partenariats bien sûr Pôle emploi a des
compétences mais l'émission locale est
Cap Emploi aussi et tout le monde doit
travailler ensemble donc je crois qu'il
faut pas mettre d'irritant et en plus
tout le monde a saisi le mot Pôle Emploi
certains parlent encore de l'ANPE donc
on va encore changer on change les
enseignes on change les logos ça coûte
combien et un jour on en a besoin
ailleurs et parmi les irritants il y
avait le rôle des collectivités dans
tout sa région de France notamment
disait que ce projet était un projet
recentralisateur hier on a posé la
question Olivier du socle qui nous
disait ne pas comprendre parce que ce
texte n'enlève absolument rien au
collectivité et à leurs compétences
est-ce que vous êtes rassuré là-dessus
alors nous on a modifié d'ailleurs
le texte à l'intérieur pour justement
toujours mettre au coeur les
collectivités territoriales parce que
nous on pense toujours que il vaut mieux
partir du terrain et remonter ensuite et
d'essayer de trouver des solutions donc
plus plus d'une fois en fait on a
modifié le texte pour justement donner
la main au collectivités territoriales
président du département qui suit tous
les bénéficiaires du RSA il doit être
vraiment au cœur en fait du dispositif
et bien sûr les communes aussi donc
voilà donc on a on a modifié aussi dans
le texte partout il y avait une forme de
recentralisation merci Alex merci à tout
à l'heure du lien social entre les
Français ce sera à suivre dans le club
merci parce qu'elle Grigny
et on va suivre évidemment ce texte dont
vous êtes la rapporteur l'examen se
poursuit cet après-midi dans les
meeticle du Sénat merci beaucoup d'avoir
été invité pendant cette première
demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires on parlera du zan le
zéro artificiel artificialisation net
c'est un sujet d'inquiétude pour les
élus députés sénateurs sont tombés
d'accord sur un texte on va recevoir le
co-auteur de ce texte Jean-Baptiste
blanc il sera notre invité d'abord on
accueille notre prochaine invité
Sébastien Chenu nous rejoint